JEANNE SHAHEEN IS A DEMOCRATIC
SENATOR AND A SENIOR MEMBER OF
BOTH THE FOREIGN RELATIONS AND
ARMED SERVICES COMMITTEES.
SHE HAS JUST COMPLETED A VISIT
TO THE BALKANS.
SHE IS NOW HERE IN LONDON FOR
TALKS IN THIS NATO ALLY HUB.
SHE JOINS ME HERE ON THE SET.
>> NICE TO BE WITH YOU.
>> WELCOME TO THE PROGRAM.
>> THANK YOU.
>> YOU SEE THE RESULT OF
AMERICAN AND NATO SUPPORT FOR
YOUR UKRAINIAN ALLIES.
IT IS ALSO VERY RISKY NOW AND
HIGH STAKES.
OR ARE YOU THINKING AS YOU SIT
HERE?
YOU JUST COME BACK FROM CLOSE
TO THAT REGION.
>> WELL, IT GOES TO SHOW WHY
THIS ALLIED PARTNERSHIP WITH
THE WEST AND NATO IN SUPPORT OF
UKRAINE IS SO IMPORTANT.
THE SUPPLIES WE ARE GIVING
UKRAINE HAS ALLOWED THEM TO
TAKE BACK LYMAN, AN IMPORTANT
TRANSPORTATION HUB.
THE RUSSIANS WERE PLANNING TO
USE IT AS A LOGISTICS OPERATION
TO SUPPLY DONETSK AND LUHANSK.
THIS HAS BEEN AN IMPORTANT
VICTORY FOR UKRAINE.
AS THE REPORT POINTED OUT,
THERE'S A LOT MORE THAT HAS TO
BE DONE.
>> THERE'S A LOT MORE THAT HAS
TO BE DONE TO GAIN BACK THE
TERRITORY.
HOW MUCH MORE WILL THE U.S. AND
NATO TOLERATE BEYOND OR BEFORE
THEY THINK THAT IT MIGHT PUTIN
INTO DOING SOMETHING REALLY
INADMISSIBLE?
ARE YOU WORRIED ABOUT THAT?
>> I THINK WE ARE ALL WORRIED
ABOUT WHAT PUTIN MIGHT DO.
HE'S ACTING IRRATIONALLY.
GOING INTO UKRAINE IN THAT
UNPROVOKED WAR, THINKING HE WAS
GOING TO TAKE OVER THE COUNTRY
FOR HIS OWN EXPANSION DREAMS, I
THINK THAT WAS IRRATIONAL.
THAT'S ALL THE MORE REASON WHY
IT IS VERY IMPORTANT FOR THE
WEST TO STAY UNITED.
I HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO MEET
WITH FOUR WOMEN UKRAINIAN
SOLDIERS LAST WEEK.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT ONE
YOUNG WOMAN SERGEANT TOLD ME,
AND SHE HAD BEEN FIGHTING IN
THE EASTERN REGION OF UKRAINE
FOR YEARS NOW, YOU NEED TO GIVE
US THE WEAPONS SO THAT WE CAN
FIGHT SO THAT YOU DON'T HAVE
TO.
I TALKED TO MY CONSTITUENTS.
WE IN THE SENATE BELIEVE THAT
IT IS IMPORTANT FOR US TO
CONTINUE TO HAVE OUR SUPPORT
FOR UKRAINE, TO PARTNER VERY
CLOSELY WITH OUR ALLIES, AND
THE PARTNERSHIP WE HAVE WITH
THE UNITED KINGDOM.
THAT HAS BEEN VERY IMPORTANT IN
THAT.
WE CAN HELP THE UKRAINIANS TO
FEED THE RUSSIANS AND HOLD
PUTIN ACCOUNTABLE.
>> YOU ARE A POLITICIAN.
MANY POLITICAL LEADERS ARE IN A
BIND RIGHT NOW.
THEY ARE SAYING, HOW MUCH MORE
OF THIS CAN WE INFLICT ON OUR
PEOPLE --
INFLATION, FOOD POVERTY, ENERGY,
SOARING ENERGY PRICES BECAUSE
OF WHAT PUTIN IS DOING.
YOU HAVE COME BACK BELIEVING
THAT THE ALLIANCE CAN STAY
TOGETHER FOR AS LONG AS IT HAS
TO.
>> I THINK IT IS IMPORTANT THAT
--
WHAT HISTORY TELLS US IS THAT
WE DON'T STOP THE ATTACK OR
AUTHORITARIAN DICTATOR NOW THAT
HE HAS OTHER DESIGNS, DESIGNS
BEYOND UKRAINE.
I WAS JUST IN BOSNIA, THE
WESTERN WALL CANS, AND YOU CAN
SEE THE EVIDENCE OF RUSSIA'S
DISINFORMATION IN THE BALKANS,
OF THEIR MEDDLING, OF THEY'RE
TRYING TO SEPARATE THE --
PART OF BOSNIA AND HERZEGOVINA.
THEY WILL CONTINUE TO DO THAT.
THEY ARE TRYING TO PICK OFF --
>> THEY ARE TRYING TO PICK OFF
THAT AREA THAT HAS BEEN STUCK
TOGETHER SINCE THE PEACE
ACCORDS AFTER THE WAR.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
IT'S NOT JUST THERE.
THEY ARE ALSO ACTIVE IN SERBIA.
THEY ARE ACTIVE IN CROATIA NO.
WE KNOW THAT THE BALTIC STATES
ARE AMONG RUSSIAN INTERVENTION.
WHAT WE HEARD FROM MELANIA WAS
THAT THEY ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
WHAT IS HAPPENING.
IT IS SOMETHING THAT WE NEED TO
WORK ON NOW BECAUSE IT IS IN
OUR ALLIED INTEREST TO DO THAT.
IT'S IN THE UNITED STATES
NATIONAL SECURITY INTEREST.
>> IT WAS THE U.S., WASN'T IT,
BACK IN 1995, THAT LED A NATO
MISSION TO GET BACK INTO THE
GENOCIDAL FORCES OF SERBIA AND
THE BOSNIAN SERBS?
I SPOKE TO THE PRIME MINISTER
OF BOSNIA.
I KNOW YOU ARE NEXT DOOR IN
ALBANIA.
HE SAID THIS TO ME.
HE SAID THAT HE WAS VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT WHAT, YOU KNOW,
ABOUT THE SERBIAN GOVERNMENT IN
BELGRADE AND ABOUT RUSSIA
THROUGH ITS SERBIAN PROXIES
AGAIN SEEKING TO DESTABILIZE
THE REGION, INCLUDING KOSOVO.
THIS IS WHAT HE SAID.
>> IF IT WOULDN'T HAVE BEEN FOR
THE SUPPORT FROM BELGRADE, I
THINK THAT SERBS IN BOSNIA,
SERVES IN MONTENEGRO, SERVES IN
KOSOVO WOULD ALL INTEGRATE IN
RESPECTIVE COUNTRIES.
IT IS BELGRADE WHO PAYS PEOPLE
IN ALL THESE COUNTRIES IN ORDER
TO SABOTAGE THE FUNCTIONALITY
OF THE STATE, TO DISOBEYED TO
THE RULE OF LAW, AND SO FORTH.
DID YOU GET THAT IMPRESSION
THAT YOU WERE THERE, THAT IF IT
WASN'T FOR THAT KIND OF
MEDDLING, THERE WOULD BE, YOU
KNOW, A MUCH MORE COHESIVE A
DEMOCRATIC PROCESS?
>> THERE IS A LONG HISTORY OF
ETHNIC TENSIONS IN THE REGION.
HAVING RUSSIA THERE TO EXPLOIT
THOSE TENSIONS MAKES IT MUCH
HARDER TO GET THINGS DONE.
WE SAW WITH PRESIDENT --
WELL, WHEN HE WAS AT THE UN,
COMING TO THIS AGREEMENT WITH
LAVROV, THE FOREIGN SECRETARY
OF RUSSIA, --
THAT WAS NOT DESIGNED TO
ENCOURAGE AN AGREEMENT AMONG
THE COUNTRIES AND THE WESTERN
BALKANS.
>> IT'S PRETTY SCARY.
WITH THE SABER-RATTLING, PEOPLE
ARE BEGINNING TO WAKE UP AND --
MANY OF THIS GENERATION WE'RE
NOT AWARE OF THE CUBAN MISSILE
CRISIS.
THEY THOUGHT THAT WITH THE END
OF THE COLD WAR THIS WAS A
THING OF THE PAST.
IT IS SO REAL NOW.
THIS IS WHAT THE NATIONAL
SECURITY SPOKESMAN JOHN KIRBY
SAID ABOUT THE IDEA THAT RUSSIA
WOULD BE DEFENDING ITS
TERRITORY IN UKRAINE.
THIS IS WHAT HE SAID ABOUT THE
ANNEXED TERRITORIES.
>> IT IS NOT AN ATTACK ON
RUSSIA.
IT IS UKRAINIAN SOIL.
IT WAS UKRAINIAN SOIL.
IT IS TODAY.
IT WILL BE TOMORROW.
WE ARE NOT IN THE BUSINESS OF
TELLING PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY HOW
HE GOES ABOUT CONDUCTING
MILITARY OPERATIONS.
WHAT WE ARE DOING IS MAKING
SURE HE HAS THE CAPABILITIES
AND CONSISTENCE THAT HE NEEDS
TO DO THIS AND HE IS.
>> I'M GOING TO GET TO HE IS IN
A SECOND.
I WANT TO KNOW WHAT YOU THINK
ABOUT THE THREAT LEVEL.
WHERE IS IT NOW IN TERMS OF THE
POSSIBILITY OF TACTICAL NUKES
OR AN ATTACK, A CONVENTIONAL
ATTACK, ON A NATO ARMS DEPOT OR
ANYTHING LIKE THAT?
>> WELL, WE KNOW THAT VLADIMIR
PUTIN IS SUFFERING LOSSES.
HE DOESN'T HAVE A LOT OF
OPTIONS NOW.
I THINK IT'S VERY CONCERNING,
HIS RHETORIC AND HIS
LONG-STANDING POLICY OF RUSSIA
TO CONSIDER ESCALATING TO
DE-ESCALATE, THIS POLICY THAT
THEY TALK ABOUT.
THEY HAVE TACTICAL NUKES THAT
THEY SAY THEY ARE WILLING TO
USE, WHICH IS ALL THE MORE
REASON WHY THAT WE NEED TO STAY
UNITED.
WE NEED TO BE VERY CLEAR WITH
VALERIE PUTIN.
THERE ARE CONSEQUENCES FOR THE
KIND OF ACTION HE IS TALKING
ABOUT.
AN ATTACK ON A NATO COUNTRY --
BIDEN HAS BEEN VERY CLEAR AND
THE NATO COUNTRIES HAVE BEEN
CLEAR THAT AN ATTACK ON A NATO
COUNTRY IS AN ATTACK ON ALL OF
US.
I DON'T THINK IT IS IN PUTIN'S
INTEREST OR RUSSIA'S INTEREST
TO ATTACK NATO.
>> WHAT WOULD IT LOOK LIKE?
WHAT ARE THE CATASTROPHIC
CONSEQUENCES?
JAKE SULLIVAN SAID --
DAVID PETRAEUS SUGGESTED THAT
NATO, WITH CONVENTIONAL WARFARE,
WOULD SINK EVERY SHIP IN RUSSIA
BLACK SEA FLEET, WOULD ATTACK
AND ELIMINATE RUSSIAN TROOP
CONSEQUENCES.
WHAT DOES IT LOOK LIKE, A
RESPONSE FROM NATO?
>> WELL, I THINK ALL OF THOSE
ARE THE KINDS OF POTENTIAL
RESPONSES AND OPTIONS THAT THE
UNITED STATES AND NATO HAVE FOR
AN ATTACK.
I THINK LEAVING THOSE TO PUTIN
'S IMAGINATION WOULD BE
IMPORTANT.
I THINK WE WANT TO LAY OUT FOR
HIM WHAT OUR OPTIONS ARE.
WE ARE NOT GOING TO TELL HIM
EXACTLY HOW WE ARE GOING TO
RESPOND.